there is a stunning new poll
out of the red state of georgia in which
democratic presidential challenger joe
biden
is winning against donald trump by one
point
this is absolutely and completely insane
and probably not indicative that biden
is going to win georgia and i want to
talk about that in a moment there's
actually a lot to talk about here
and this is really going to get us into
a discussion of the role of polling
going forward from now until november
3rd
the last time let's start in georgia the
last time that a democratic presidential
candidate won georgia was 28 years ago
was bill clinton in 1992
it was a squeaker bill clinton winning
by
0.5 percent of the vote over george h.w
bush but notice if you're watching that
there was a third party candidate ross
perot
who did get 13 of the vote in georgia so
the last time that a democrat won
georgia
without a significant third party
candidate was
1980 40 years ago when jimmy carter
defeated ronald reagan
but that was jimmy carter's home state
so the last time stick with me here
that a democratic presidential candidate
won georgia
in a two-way race when georgia was
not their home state was 1960
when john f kennedy defeated richard
nixon brutally 62-37
that was 60 years ago so
when we see a poll today that says
biden's winning by one in georgia
to me it's a signal that it could be a
bad november for trump
it's not really a signal that biden's
going to win florida the average i'm
sorry georgia
the average in georgia is still trump
winning by 1.6
but the important thing about the latest
cbs news poll
which has biden plus one is that it's
using a likely voter model instead of a
registered voter model and i've talked
to you before about the importance of
this
if you just survey adults that's
considered the least accurate because
half the country doesn't vote if you
survey registered voters
it is considered more accurate because
you're at least restricting
the poll to people who are registered to
vote many registered voters don't vote
but it's more accurate than just all
adults because many adults just aren't
even registered and they never vote
likely voter is arguably if done
correctly
the most accurate and so that's a good
thing that's a good sign that as we
start to see registered voter models
become likely voter models as we close
in on november
the polling should become more accurate
that being said this poll
that has joe biden winning by one in
georgia has a 3.4
margin of error so what that means is
the poll could actually be in reality
biden is at 42.6 and trump is at 48.4
like that's what the margin of error
means so
this poll which has biden plus one could
actually be
trump plus six and be within the margin
of error so what that means is
we should take nothing from this other
then
everybody's gotta vote whether you think
your state will be close
or not you've gotta vote i do not
believe trump will win georgia
but if enough polls say it's tight maybe
trump has to spend money there maybe
trump has to campaign
uh two georgians that's a victory
getting republicans to have to spend
money
in georgia in texas etc
that's a good thing so the big picture
of this
sort of battleground and moderate rates
red state polling is that trump is now
according to new polling losing by four
in north carolina
losing by one in georgia there is some
texas polling that has trump down
the meaning of it is this is a really
bad presidency
that's the takeaway given the
hyper-polarized nature of the country
right now
when you look at these traditionally red
states and you see that it looks like
it's close
that means that there are some partisan
right wingers that are realizing this is
so bad that i'm at least as of right now
not yet committed to support donald
trump uh you know
maga will be maga trump will still get
tens of millions of votes that's an
indictment of our country no doubt
but there is actually some reason that
is
in injecting itself
embedding itself in the brains of some
committed right-wingers but we can't
forgive the ignorance if our population
had been
better at critical thinking and had done
10 minutes of actual research back in
2016
trump never would have been the nominee
and certainly never would have become
president of the united states many of
the unnecessary coronavirus deaths that
we've had
would would not have happened and that
number is likely to hit 160 000 in the
next day or two so what we want to do
here is understand what's happening so
that it doesn't happen again
starting with this november but we can't
forget how it happened
we can't ignore that it could happen
again and it still might happen again
in november if we don't vote so to go
back to georgia for a moment
it's not just that there's a margin of
error and trump might actually be
winning like that's one one
interpretation would be
okay biden's plus one but you look at
the margin of error
could really be trump plus six that's
that's one part of it
the other part of it is when you look at
the history of voter suppression in
georgia
when you look at the planned voter
suppression in georgia
it should give us zero confidence that
these close
states are even going to have a shot at
going our way
unless we completely overwhelm the
voting
in november so it's a sad reality
there's a lot we're up against right now
and it includes
five or six different ways in which
donald trump is going to try to suppress
the vote we have to accept it and work
with it and what that means is
so overwhelming voting turnout and every
every election both sides say it we're
our side's motivated we're going to have
record turnout and very often
particularly among some voting groups it
doesn't
happen we actually have to do that to
overwhelm
trump kneecapping the post office voter
purges
limiting vote by mail and on and on and
on that's the only way forward